Today I just want to
show people how to get
started, making
a basic Shiny app
and just understanding
the basic concepts.
In order to do that, we can
just start from the website.
This is the Shiny
for Python website.
It's shiny.rstudio.com/py.
I know that might be really
little in the browser,
but we'll post a link for that.
And the easiest way to get
started just working on code
is just click on examples.
And that will take you to
this website, shinylive.io,
where you can just
work on your code here.
You can look at the
examples, edit the code,
and run the apps.
And this is one of the
most exciting things,
I think, is that
you can use Shiny
without having to
install anything,
without having to install
even Python on your system.
You can just get in here and
start working right away.
And then as you
develop an app that
becomes more sophisticated, you
can work in a regular Python
installation, but
to get started,
this is a great way to do it.
So let's take a look
at this example app.
There's a whole bunch of
different examples over here,
but by default, it just
starts on this page.
And to understand how a
Shiny application is built,
there's two main components.
There's the ui, which
is the part that's
displayed in the web browser.
This is a web page that's
displayed in the web
browser over here, and then
there's the server logic,
and this is Python code that
gets executed when somebody
connects to this application.
It executes this code
once, and then it
will re-execute reactive
functions in response
to user input.
So there's a ui here,
there's the server code here,
and then that stuff gets put
together into a Shiny app
object over here.
And so we're calling
this app object App.
That's what you have to call
it for this all to work.
Let's take a look at the ui.
So in this case, we
have an input slider,
which is this thing over here,
and then output_text_verbatim.
So this is a text
output, and the verbatim
means that it's printed as code
with a monospace font instead
of being printed as
normal HTML text.
And as we change this slider,
it causes this output to change.
All right, so we've got
this input and this output
component, and they're
wrapped up inside of something
called a page fluid.
Now, we don't have to know the
details about this right now,
but for most applications
at this point,
we can just wrap these
components in a page fluid.
All right, so now what's
connecting them together
is this server logic here.
This is a function.
It's called server.
And as I said earlier,
it gets executed once
when the user connects
to the application.
Now, there's a bunch of
these decorators here.
This is saying we've got
this thing that's an output,
it's rendering text,
and then here we have--
we're defining the function
txt, which returns a string.
Now, I'm going to change
some of these names just
to make it a little
easier to explain things.
So let's say we'll call
this slider my_slider
and input.my_slider and text,
call it txt_computation.
All right, we'll put
this over here as well.
So I made some changes
to this application.
I'm just going to--
I can click this
button to rerun it.
Now it looks the same, but
over here, the variables
should be-- it'll be
a little easier to see
how things line up.
So I've got the slider input,
and the ID of it is my_slider,
and then I can read it in
this function down here.
So I can say input.my_slider,
and then I invoke that
as a function, and this function
will return the current value
of the slider.
And then what I'm
doing with that value
is I'm putting into a string.
And this function,
txt_computation, it
takes this string
and it's sticking it
into this output_text_verbatim.
One of the cool
things about Shiny
is its reactive computing model.
So if I move this
slider, I don't
have to do anything
extra to tell
it to re-execute this function.
It just knows, like, hey,
input.my_slider's changed,
so re-execute this function
every time I do that.
All right, now I can do
some other things to this.
I can change this label here.
I can say you input a
value here, and I can--
because this is all running
within the web browser,
Python is running
in the web browser
and Shiny is running
in the web browser,
I can just click
this button here
and re-execute this
application every time
I make changes to it.
So it makes it really easy
to try out new things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]